previously on the adventure men who
tried so we've got talking cats I am
down we've never done cosplay before you
guys should definitely feel some
pressure have you seen a lot of
post-apocalyptic punk rock eighties glam
meet subdued Sailor Scouts before so
with the aid of the talking cat friend
our brave adventurer men set forth on a
journey to Anime Expo determined to be
the best cosplayers this world has ever
seen try guys try cosplay episode 3 the
try guys cosplay for the first time oh
my god we are here at the beautiful LA
Convention Center
it's crazy already there's a hundred
thousand people here today it's nuts
what's up Anime Expo 2k15 oh man I've
been faxing that for the masquerade I'm
excited for the masquerade we found out
there's a 40-foot LED screen behind us
it's like a giant stage and there are
lights and stuff and I'm like a stickler
for like you know perfection like I want
everything to be on point hopefully we
don't get all up probably gonna [ __ ]
something up this whole process leading
up has been really tough building these
costumes takes a long time a lot of
effort people here looking just driving
up we saw like really like to the tee
costumes of like anime characters you
see people that you know and you're like
what's not Wario love the ballet people
obviously have been putting a lot of
time and care into their costumes
working for months for this one day not
just hobby for people but it's a
lifestyle
I'm a beautiful galaxy princess so we're
here with Tim Wyckoff Tim what are we
getting ourselves into today so much so
freaking much you guys are about to go
out to the largest enemy convention in
North America hundred thousand people
looking insanely awesome people are
going to help you you're not gonna be
able to walk people are going to scream
we have screamers at enemy x but their
little yeah I'm super excited to get
into the the fray of everybody else
dressed up getting anxious I just want
to get out there they're really proud
about the costume all these little
pieces all came together I had so much
fun making your costumes like I'm so
proud of what we did and I'm just like
I'm excited to just get out there and
show off what we did to people know what
we did I'm excited to show off what we
did ,
to people it made sense it's a sentence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I want to play DDR that's all I want to
play
[Music]
it's a tuxedo mask
so we were out there for about half an
hour so I'll play this game I hate it oh
god it's not bad and then all of our
costumes started falling apart
I would keep sprawling up my be careful
because we're already getting amazing
parts of the costume it's hard enough to
just assembly your costume for the first
time but then you have to maintain it
all day the second we walked out the
door my bubble gun stopped working I may
also within 30 minutes I started getting
hurt by Eugene's horrific sorry sorry
about my fire both eyes my fire bow so I
have a very spiky fire bow oh there's a
baby I told you about that
I just wanted to cosplay good otherwise
I mean it's really fun there's lots of
people are excited to see us that's
great we're just hoping to keep our
costumes up the bar also earlier Eugene
said that Ned looked like a lesbian it's
a compliment in the highest order but
now we're gonna actually go to the main
floor and do like real cosplay posing
and interacting after we figure out how
to make everything stick to us without
falling off how many photos do you think
we can expect to take today thousands
and I'm not kidding as soon as you stop
to take pictures from someone you're
gonna be stopped there for probably a
good 20 minutes
we're down you're the living embodiment
of their favorite things
[Music]
Wow
this one little thing about cosplaying
for animation or comic books they don't
exist in real life those people are on a
page you're bringing them to life so we
all agree that Sailor Mars is the best
right I am so excited that you made this
yours you took something classic you
took Sailor Moon you turned into
something that you believe in that you
have fun with and that's what cosplay is
about having fun
no my favorite part of the entire
experience was our Sailor Venus here
talking to people in the same what's
your name what's your name what so uh we
are gonna just take a break real quick
before we go down and do an official
photo shoot with our cosplay so that's
what we're doing next so what is
involved in making a great cosplay photo
shoot great costumes
good location yeah I'll let it get into
the feel on your character maybe
practice a little bit in front of the
mirror so you kind of know your body a
little bit I know a lot about cute socks
I know a lot about using body I know a
lot about that body great tillery's you
thank you just have fun relax just be
silly are so simple you got to tell us
what to do and how to pose what's the
cutesy one who's the Cutie one out of
the group he's the guilty one we mark
you see wow thanks Destiny's Child make
love to the camera be Beyonce
give him some blue steel yeah a really
serious
make sure your hair is right my hair
that's a part of cosplay you have to
beat become your character
guys are getting really good at this now
give us some to ie so we're also gonna
be performing at the masquerade Anime
Expo and if you're the opening act Wow
wait were the opening one is the mask
wait hold the hold up that is news time
we're opening the show so we've never
done it and we're gonna yes a this is
how you do we have to be really well a
question any judge should ask what is
the masquerade what is it see this so
every con has a masquerade which is
basically it's a competition wait so is
it like a beauty pageant where you walk
across stage where is their performance
involved um both people can sign up and
show their skills show off their costume
and win awards and then there are skits
where someone maybe who did Elsa will
sing let it go so it's a chance to you
know make a performance and be the
character and bring them to life a
little bit more oh man I don't even know
about the masquerade is anyone needs to
be talking to about where the placement
is of everything so I have not had any
time to practice the dance or the sketch
I'm excited but I'm cautious I just want
us to do a good job I hope that they
don't look at us and say like who are
these idiots hopefully we don't get all
up it's only 4000 people that we
disappoint probably gonna something up
but I want to rock up out tonight I'm
also trying not to swear today I
reserved a bit let's do this you're
pretty dirty
yeah we're really really pretty
[Applause]
romance is a waste time here the same
space sending fires with my grace giving
evil all the taste and the blaze is
hotter than a page from the chips
region oh my god melted people's faces
everybody loved my song it was perfect
and our sketch went great
we were adorable and PI notice me me and
I'll make you one we cut you like a
knife
I screwed some things up I like mr. Qi
mr. line no one cared we just put all
our energy into it and we just had a
great time your families for long so
this whole underlying theme of
acceptance in the cosplay community I
think is what really sets it apart from
a lot of other subcultures and I think
that's the bottom line about cosplay
come as you are
have fun whatever speaks to your heart
let it out people are gonna have a good
time with you
[Applause]
the guys are all such amazing people you
inspire each other you inspire us thank
you for letting us be a part of this
awesome event thank you guys so much
in the name
[Applause]
man I am exhausted oh you guys there was
so much work my costume was falling
apart all day mine didn't fall apart but
then I dropped my goggles in the urinal
what's great about is that no one gives
a [ __ ] you really could be wearing
whatever and if you like working it and
you've passion for it someone out there
is gonna appreciate it it's such a crazy
energy in this whole place so it's that
we only came one day I would have gone
the whole weekend oh my goodness people
got engaged
roxrite has countered with the health I
love you marry me
it exemplified the spirit of this whole
weekend people sharing their passions
sharing that love with each other I know
I thought about all of it I really want
it's okay what I've learned is that I
want to cosplay more in the future all
of us I didn't just had such a great
time I get it I had a good time this is
fun
I like costumes we stay here for a year
no one will know we're using our costume
together you get the be pleased that the
madam
daddy likey